I'm taking a low dose of Armour Thyroid as well as standard process thyrofen, thyrofen
protomarkogen. My lab numbers are a little bit better. I would give them to you, but the
website is glitchy and it won't let me in. I am not eating gluten. Are there other things
you could suggest to encourage healing from Hashimoto's? Yes, I'd encourage going on the
autoimmune course. You have access to the autoimmune course. All of you guys do and there's I think
its module five or six is all about Hashimoto's. So there's other, so if a person has Hashimoto's
if you have self antibodies, if you have any autoimmune disease whatsoever, that means you have self
antibodies. You have to be aware of and be searching for triggers. What are triggers?
Triggers that are stimulating immune spike, that stimulating destruction of the tissue which you
have antibodies against and causing symptoms. So going through that whole course will be beneficial
certainly looking at the section the module of Hashimoto's would be beneficial as well.